je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
mais je le dit on parle de 150 mille
enfants donc amérindiens métis et inuits
qui ont été envoyés dans ces pensionnats
comment ça s'est passé le début de cette
politique coloniale était devenir un
territoire étranger en france sans le
consentement des parents et les
arachides leur pays toit pour les amis
dans d'autres régions dans deux
provinces très très loin l'objectif
était de tuer l'envié dans la fin juin
justement 182 tombes anonymes ont été à
découverte sur le site d'un ancien
pensionnat à cranbrook en colombie
britannique s est la troisième
découverte de ce type en un mois on
parle ici de génocide de politique
génocidaire sa voix au delà de la
culture mais plutôt un crime contre
l'humanité observe une nation
ep
[Musique]
la france va fournir 100 millions
d'euros des directs à la population
libanaise dans les mois à venir après la
double explosion au port qui a décimé la
ville de beyrouth ce emmanuel macron
peut faire pression sur les dirigeants
politiques alors que le pays est dans
l'impasse et s'enfonce dans une crise
sans précédent
l' enquête pour trouver les responsables
piétine et la population libanaise
demande la vérité la corse l'occitanie à
la région paca à l'épreuve du variant
delta face à la flambée des cas le plan
blanc a été déclenché dans ces trois
régions le nombre de personnes en
réanimation a augmenté ces derniers
jours
parallèlement la contestation des
soignants s'organise il dénonce
l'obligation vaccinale à laquelle ils
sont soumis des syndicats appellent à la
grève illimitée
[Musique]
les talibans revendiquent l'attentât
suicide qui a visé le ministre afghan de
la défense bismullah mohammadi à kaboul
qui lui s'en sort un bm après s'être
déjà emparée des territoires dans les
campagnes les insurgés mettent la
pression sur les grands centres urbains
l'offensive militaire des talibans se
rapproche de jour en jour des grandes
villes afghanes face à une armée qui
peine à les faire reculer
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur arte
france très heureuse de vous retrouver
il est 20 heures des vacances studieuses
pour emmanuel macron au fort de
brégançon le chef de l'état a réuni les
principaux acteurs de la communauté
internationale un an après l'explosion
du port de beyrouth pour apporter une
nouvelle aide d'urgence direct de 100
millions d'euros aux libanais joe biden
a promis elle la même somme selon l'onu
350 millions de dollars vont être
reversés pour subvenir aux besoins de la
population qui se paupérise le président
français exhorte les dirigeants libanais
à former un gouvernement
c'est la priorité selon lui écoute elle
je suis aujourd'hui en mesure de vous
annoncer que nous allons dans les mois
qui viennent mettre en place près de 100
millions d'euros de nouveaux engagements
en appui direct à la population du liban
pour ce qui concerne la france s'est
elle portera sur l'éducation avec un
soutien exceptionnel aux familles et aux
élèves aux étudiants elle portera sur
l'aide alimentaire et nous allons en
outre accroître notre soutien à
l'agriculture dans ce cadre-là la santé
restera aussi une priorité absolue et je
veux ici est annoncée également l'envoi
de 500 mille doses de vaccin contre le
coc vide dans les prochaines semaines et
donc durant ce mois d'août première des
priorités reste cela la formation d'un
gouvernement chargé des mesures les plus
urgentes au service de la population ce
qui permettra à la communauté
internationale d'appuyer encore
davantage le libre les dirigeants
libanais semble faire le pari du
pourrissement
je le regrette je pense que c'est une
faute historique et morale c'était il ya
un an jour pour jour le 4 août 2020 à
18h07 heure locale qu une double
explosion au port des cimes la ville de
beyrouth le triste anniversaire de cette
catastrophe continue de hanter le pays
qui s'enfonce dans une crise sans
précédent
économique et social elle les libanais
réclame la vérité et demande à ce que
les responsables soient punis
mais un an après l enquête est au point
mort la population continue de se
soulever
des manifestations ont lieu en ce moment
même dans tout le pays
elle est libanais qui défilent en
mémoire des deux cent quatorze hommes
femmes et enfants qui ont perdu la vie
lors de ce triste 4 août elle et
précision à d'alexis fond
[Musique]
c'était il ya un an
4' 2020
une double explosion dans le port de
beyrouth fait 214 morts
six mille cinq cent blessés selon le
ministère de la santé libanais
dizaines de milliers de personnes se
retrouvent sans logement
la ville est dévastée
les dégâts considérables le monde entier
sous le choc
à l'origine de cette terrible
catastrophe de 1700 tonnes de nitrate
d'ammonium un agent hautement explosif
entassés dans un entrepôt sans grande
précaution le soir même le premier
ministre hassan diab annonce l'ouverture
d'une enquête
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui impose
que des comptes soient rendus
les responsables de cette catastrophe
devront rendre des comptes
c'est une promesse que nous faisons aux
martyrs et aux blessés
c'est un engagement national un
engagement qu'il ne tiendra pas hassan
diab démissionne quelques jours plus
tard la capitale beyrouth s'embrase la
population libanaise déjà durement
touchée par une crise économique
historique se lance dans une
contestation qui met à jour une profonde
crise politique
[Musique]
un an plus tard l'enquète sur les
responsabilités liées à la catastrophe
est au point mort
personne n'a été inculpé un juge
d'instruction avait été récusé
après avoir mis en examen l'ancien
premier ministre
hassan diab et trois de ses ministres en
février dernier ce lundi amnesty
international a reproché aux autorités
libanaises d'entravé délibérément les
investigations dans la foulée militants
et proches des victimes ont lancé un
ultimatum au pouvoir en place pour lever
l'immunité des hauts responsables
inculpés
car pour les libanais
ces accusations sonne comme un nouveau
coup dur alors que la révolte commence à
l'emporter sur le donneur notre blessure
grandir et s'approfondit chaque jour une
année entière s'est écoulé mais nous
sommes toujours bloqués aux quatre pages
aux radars et la colère grandit d' je
demande à dieu comment je suis censé me
débarrasser de cette colère je ne sais
pas comment la colère on ne devient pas
plus forte que notre tristesse
pendant ce temps les beyrouthins peine à
reconstruire la zone dévastée
abandonnés par leurs autorités ne
peuvent compter que sur une armée de
volontaires et des ong pour continuer à
déblayer les gravats si aujourd'hui le
quartier reprend vie progressivement
les crises économiques politiques et
sanitaires elle semble être loin d'être
terminée journée de mobilisation à
beyrouth mais pas seulement à paris une
cérémonie en hommage aux victimes a été
organisée on fait le point avec notre
reporter david khalfa écoutez le de la
tristesse et surtout de la colère pour
ces manifestants venus en nombre aux
alentours de l'ambassade du liban afin
de rendre hommage
évidemment dans un premier temps aux
victimes de cette terrible explosion qui
a eu lieu il ya un an au port de à
beyrouth mais aussi là pour réclamer
justice
un an après toujours aucun responsable
n'a été désigné plusieurs centaines de
personnes sont venues rendre hommage à
ces victimes des bougies ont été a
disposé devant les photos de celle de
114 victimes à des prises de parole se
sont succédé mais également des drapeaux
ont été distribués à tous les
participants à ce rassemblement
l'initiative d' emmanuel macron de cette
conférence internationale afin de
récolter des fonds organisée aujourd'hui
à part le président français a été salué
par les manifestants mais elle n'est pas
suffisante pour huit mois n'a pas en
fait confiance dans notre gouvernement
n'a pas confiance dans nos politiciens
et ce qui n'est pas
qui a promis en fait un manuel mac ans
et partira directement aux gens via des
désorganisations non gouvernementaux
mais c'est pas suffisant faire ce que la
destruction qui a eu au liban les
soixante sept mille maisons qui ont été
détruites
nous ne ferons pas vraiment être
reconstruite comme ça avec le peu de
temps qu'on reçoit on a besoin que tout
le monde se mobilise que tout ce que
tous les états se mobilisent en fait
pour le liban je demande au président de
la république de mettre aux actes aux
maux qui sont 10 soit il est un
président marketing et l'assument
soit il est un président d'action et il
le fait yannick jadot a multiplié les
initiatives mais visiblement elle ne
sont pas elles sont pas entendus alors
moi j'invite tous celles et tous ceux
qu'elle que soit notre obédience laisser
nos conflits de côté et aller de l'avant
aller de l'avant pour ce peuple frère ce
peuple est en train de mourir à petit
feu sous sous nos yeux sous la
communauté internationale nous avons une
responsabilité
nous devons l'assumer et cette colère
elle est significative car en un an
aucun responsable n'a été jugé en parle
de négligence criminelle est impunité
des responsables qui connaissait
l'existence à de l'énorme stock de
nitrate d'ammonium entre opposé pendant
des années sans précaution dans un
hangar à du port de beyrouth et dont la
sondhi a provoqué cet énorme explosion
qui je le rappelle a fait plus de 200
victimes et des milliers de blessés
est la descente aux enfers continue pour
le pays du cèdre un rapport de la banque
mondiale a classé la crise économique et
financière du liban parmi les trois
épisodes de crises les plus graves du
monde depuis le milieu du 19e siècle une
situation jamais connu même pendant la
guerre civile de 1975 et crise politique
et économique paupérisation de la
population dévaluation de la monnaie
locale et pour couronner le tout la
pénurie d'essence qui paralyse tout le
pays et maxime abers comme si cela ne
suffisait pas confrontés à une crise
sanitaire économique et politique
les libanais doivent désormais faire
face à une pénurie d'essence
parmi les premières victimes les
services de santé à l'hôpital bint jbeil
dans le sud du pays
le manque de carburant menace la santé
sinon la vie des patients
le gasoil est vital pour le bon
fonctionnement des hôpitaux on utilise
en chirurgie pour les patients
cardiaques ou en soins intensifs et
risque de perdre la vie en raison de
cette pénurie
autre conséquence la pénurie oblige
nombre de chauffeurs de bus a stoppé le
travail ou avoir recours à l'économie
souterraine
parfois nous achetons de l'essence au
marché noir
en fait on le fait tout le temps on doit
travailler pour nourrir nos familles
voilà pourquoi nous achetons au marché
noir
autre secteur touché par cette crise du
carburant celui de l'agriculture
son fuel les stations de pompage
fonctionne à moitié impossible donc pour
les agriculteurs et les habitants de
s'approvisionner en eau alors ils s'en
remettent aux camions citernes qui eux
aussi font la queue pour récupérer le
précieux liquide
mais cela fait souffrir tout le monde
pas seulement les propriétaires de
citernes mais aussi les clients
aujourd'hui si un client veut de l'eau
font camions citernes demandera d'abord
de l'essence
cette pénurie s'explique par plusieurs
facteurs le plus important l'incapacité
pour la banque du liban d'ouvrir
davantage de lignes de crédit et par
conséquence l'impossibilité pour l'état
de payer puis faire circuler leurs noirs
sur le marché local à cela il faut
ajouter la contrebande vers le voisin
syrien ou le sans plomb se vend dix fois
plus cher
si aujourd'hui les compagnies de
distribution affirment que des navires
remplis de carburant sont arrivés au
liban les stations-service pour la
plupart restent fermés de retour en
france où le variant belle tu as gagné
du terrain la flambée des cas qui
comptent qui compromet de plus en plus
les vacances d'été dans certaines villes
touristiques du finistère le port du
masque en extérieur a fait son retour
le plan blanc a été activé en corse paca
et occitanie une procédure qui permet
notamment de rappeler est des soignants
en congé de déprogrammer des opérations
et d'ouvrir des filières supplémentaires
et face à la flambée épidémique le
gouvernement veut agir et vite notamment
à grâce à une nouvelle loi qui doit
encore être validée par le conseil
constitutionnel
elle prévoit entre autre l extension du
pass sanitaire au lieu de vie
quotidienne et la vaccination
obligatoire des soignants ils auront
jusqu'au mois de septembre pour s'y
conformer
une nouvelle qui n'enchante pas les
syndicats qui appellent à une grève
illimitée
le pass sanitaire serait une mesure
coûteuse à appliquer dans les hôpitaux
60 millions d'euros par mois selon la
déléguée générale de la fédération
hospitalière de france écoutez la
la mise en place du pass sanitaires à
l'hôpital suppose deux choses elle
suppose à la fois de revoir les
organisations en matière d'accès et
souvent les hôpitaux ou plusieurs points
d'accès et puis ensuite elle suppose de
renforcer ses accès alors comment l'on
renforcé accès soit en recrutant du
personnel supplémentaire des contrats à
courte durée soit en faisant appel à des
sociétés extérieures des prestataires de
sécurité et donc ce que nous avons
chiffré
c'est ce renforcement de la sécurité
tu es à hauteur de 60 millions pour un
mois en termes de surcoût elle se passe
sanitaires on continue d'en parler avec
notre éditorialiste politique alexis
poulain alexis poulain bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous alors demain le conseil
constitutionnel doit statuer sur le pass
sanitaire que peut-on attendre de la
part du conseil des sages bien c'est
toujours la même chose
a priori le conseil constitutionnel a
déjà validé la constitutionnalité de
l'idée même du pass sanitaire c'était en
mai dernier
la question qui se pose à lui maintenant
c'est l'extension de ce pas salutaire et
la vaccination obligatoire pour
certaines professions
donc il va statuer mais a minima sur des
points de détail pour voir quel va être
le périmètre d'application finalement de
se passer à lithaire qui on le voit va
poser beaucoup de problèmes dans les
fêtes dans l'organisation dans la mise
en place à la fois sur la sécurisation
des hôpitaux mais aussi des lieux de vie
on parle décidément par des restaurants
on parle des transports et de et des
salles de sport enfin bref d'à peu près
partout
or les entrepreneurs commencent à voir
ou même la fédération hospitalière quand
vous venez de le montrer à voir les
coûts qui vont engendrer
finalement la mise en place de ce fameux
pass sanitaire donc on se rend compte
que entre la théorie et la pratique il
va sans doute y avoir un fossé énorme et
on va demander aux policiers qui eux
n'ont pas obligation vaccinale d'aller
vérifier de temps en temps si les gens
qui sont dans des lieux où le passé
militaire est obligatoire ont bien leurs
passes sanitaire donc entre ce qui va
être annoncé et ce qui va être réelle
vécue sur le terrain ça va être
compliqué également pour des commerçants
tension comme les restaurants où
certains restaurateurs ont déjà prévu de
mettre la clé sous la porte parce que ce
sera impossible tout simplement de
vérifier le passé l'inter alors certains
ont trouvé la parade ils demandent à des
retraités de venir vérifier les passes
sanitaire formidable ça c'est vraiment
la start up nation on est retraité et on
travaille gratuitement pour impliquer
des mesures de réduction de liberté on
peut applaudir de demain ont trouvé ça
ridicule
toujours est il que entre le choix qui
est fait de vouloir c'est toi de
limitation des libertés
l'avis du conseil constitutionnel qu'on
attend pour demain et qui risquent
d'être à minima et la réalité sur le
terrain il y aura un monde alors la
colère elle grandit
manifestation corporation et syndicats
s'insurgent contre se passe oui les
syndicats de soignants d'abord syndicats
également chez les pompiers des
professions qui serait soumis à une
vaccination obligatoire cela commence à
donner de la voix à dire qu' il n'y a
pas de raison de faire une chose
pareille alors à ce moment là il
faudrait que ce soit la même chose pour
tous certains dans la classe politique
souhaiterait une vaccination obligatoire
pour tous et et sur le passe à l'inter
on voit bien les restaurateurs
commencent à se rendre compte que c'est
se tirer une balle dans le pied alors
qu'ils ont été fermés pendant des mois
certes payé 1 grâce grâce à l'argent
public et soutenu là où la reprise
pourrait venir et bien elle ne viendra
pas parce que les pats sanitaires font
que partout dans le monde où ils ont été
installés
les clients ont déserté les commerces
qui demandait le pass sanitaires reste
la question bien sûr des centres
commerciaux
là encore c'est au préfet un de choisir
en fonction de l'état de l'épidémie dans
son département dans sa localité dans sa
région et en fonction de ça on verra des
centres commerciaux ouverts ou non pas
sanitaires ont marché sur la tête
puisque rappelons le le pass and i ter
n'est pas nécessaire pour aller dans le
métro ou le rer qui sont bondés aux
heures de pointe mais il sera nécessaire
pour boire un verre en terrasse
donc vraiment la question même de
l'utilité de se passer ni terre se pose
puisque aujourd'hui on apprend avec les
études qui s'enchaînent et se
multiplient que les vaccinés contamine
aussi tout comme les non vaccinés certes
mois mais il contamine aussi de son
porteur du virus donc pourquoi vouloir
faire un monde entre vacciner non
vaccinés alors que le vaccin n'empêche
pas la propagation du variant delta
alexis blanc vous avez énuméré toutes
toutes ces contraintes est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils maniaient macron peut
faire marche arrière alors ce n'est pas
dans sa nature
il vient de donner une interview à paris
match où il stigmatise encore davantage
les protestataires ceux qui refusent le
past and i ter en parlant de français
qui ont perdu le sens il fait exactement
les mêmes erreurs qu'il a fait lors de
les manifestations des gilet jaune c'est
à dire qu'il clive et qu'il montre du
doigt une partie de la population qui
n'est pas d'accord avec sa politique qui
critique ou qu'ils doutent
pour lui pas de doute possible il faut
vacciner tout le monde enfants dès 12
ans il faut que l'économie
repartent vite dès la rentrée peu
importe si les études commencent à se
poser des questions sur l'efficacité de
la vaccination et de la couverture
vaccinale avec les variants qui se
multiplient il faut faire comme il a
décidé d'ailleurs il
il gouverne depuis des mois en conseil
de défense en niant tout à fait les
institutions démocratiques ou du débat
parlementaire on a vu la façon dont le
débat a été passé en force à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
tout ça de manière extrêmement rapide
alors qu'on est en train de changer de
monde
l'idée d' emmanuel macron dupas
sanitaire ne pensait pas qu'elle va ça
s'envoler avec le virus avec l'épidémie
une fois finie c'est un principe de
citoyenneté à la carte
inspiré du modèle chinois qui nous
emmène très loin très loin des rives de
la démocratie libérale que nous
connaissons sans même que les débats
éthiques déontologiques et pu être posée
la cnil qui se demandent sur la
sécurisation des données de santé
le défenseur des droits aussi qui se
demande et le conseil constitutionnel
qui va certes limité la portée de ce
pass mais qui va néanmoins aller dans le
sens des manuels macro qui a grâce aux
institutions de la vème république et
les lois d'exception sous le régime
sanitaire tous les droits
dès qu'ils n'ont ne s'en prive pas
d'ailleurs puisque depuis le fort de
brégançon il donne des leçons en polo ou
en t-shirt expliquant aux uns et aux
autres pourquoi il faut faire comme il a
dit puisque c'est lui qui décide de tout
dans un pays de plus de 60 millions
d'habitants
on y est habitué c'est quand même
dommage parce que je pense que les
débats auraient à mériter davantage de
temps parce que comme je le disais entre
les desiderata d'un président isolé et
la réalité sur le terrain
il y aura un monde et on verra sans
doute le pass and i ter s'évaporer bien
plus vite que le virus
alexis poulin a été réaliste politique
merci pour toutes ces précisions
l étau se resserre encore au tour
d'andrew cuomo selon un rapport
d'enquêté indépendante publiée mardi le
gouverneur démocrate de l'état de new
york aurait harcelé sexuellement
plusieurs femmes
andré comeau elle nie les faits ont
rejoint tout de suite notre reporter à
notre correspondant à washington thomas
bonnet bonjour thomas alors le
gouverneur de l'état de new york est au
coeur d'un scandale
andrew cuomo le gouverneur démocrate a
répondu hier à une conférence de presse
accablante de la procureur de l'état
malgré son démenti sa position est
quelque peu fragilisé et président
américains réclament sa démission
oui andrew comeau c'est un gouverneur le
gouverneur de l'état de new york depuis
2011 il est donc démocrate il a une
influence au sein de ce parti et vous en
avez peut-être déjà entendu parler lors
de cette pandémie de kobe 19 puisqu'ils
s'étaient opposés à de nombreuses
reprises à la politique menée à l'époque
par le président donald trump il est
donc la cible d'accusations de
harcèlement sexuel
onze femmes témoignent contre lui et il
ya eu donc hier une conférence de presse
de la part de la procureur de l'état de
new york une conférence de presse que
l'on pourra qualifier d' accablante
puisque donc les détails de ce qui lui
est reproché à andré comeau ont été
dévoilés notamment des baisers des
étreintes non désirées un environnement
de travail toxiques au total ce sont 165
pages d'investigation qui ont été a
dévoilé hier je propose d'écouter un
extrait justement de cette conférence de
presse gainward tijerina notre enquête a
révélé qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'
incident isolé
erreur il s'inscrivait dans un schéma où
nous le comportement du gouverneur en
matière de harcèlement sexuel
non ce n'était pas aux membres de son
équipe c'est un peu aussi à d'autres
employés de l'état y compris à une
policière de l'état qui faisait partie
de sa garde rapprochée et chopper soft
alors vous pouvez l'imaginer ces
accusations ont fait l'effet d'une bombe
médiatique ici aux etats-unis et puis
quelques instants plus tard quelques
instants après cette conférence de
presse une allocution d'andrew cuomo a
été diffusée sur la quasi totalité des
chaînes d'informations ici aux
etats-unis et un exercice de
communication savamment orchestrée ou le
gouverneur de new york
elle rejette les accusations il se
définit comme quelqu'un de tactile par
nature il a d'ailleurs publié un certain
nombre de photos de lui au cours de ces
dernières années où on peut le voir en
train d'embrasser ou d'étreindre un
certain nombre de personnes comme pour
expliquer qu'il n'y avait absolument
aucune ambiguïté dans ses gestes
ecoutez-la donc là la locution d'andrew
comeau qui a été diffusé hier
wright do better with pipe je plaisante
avec les gens je dis des blagues
certaines meilleurs que d'autres
je suis la même personne en public et en
privé je comprends maintenant qu'il ya
des perspectives générationnel 1
culturel qu'honnêtement je n'avais pas
totalement apprécié et j'ai appris que
cela une allocution qui a remis une
pièce dans la machine transformant cette
affaire en un véritable feuilleton
politico médiatique faisant la une de
tous les médias y compris de la chaîne
cnn une chaîne où officie le frère
d'andrew comeau il s'appelle chris
comeau il anime quotidiennement une
tranche d'information le soir donc sur
l'antenne de cnn
et hier soir il n'a pas dit un seul mot
sur cette affaire qui agite et pourtant
évidemment la sphère médiatique
américaine il faut dire que son frère
dont chris comeau a aidé le gouverneur
de new york a préparé sa stratégie pour
répondre à ces accusations de
harcèlement sexuel
évidemment vous pouvez l'imaginer la
pression est très forte autour du
gouverneur de new york
pour ce qui est des pour qu'il
démissionne la question a même été posée
au président américain joe biden
hier suite à une conférence de presse
sur un tout autre sujet sur le kobe de
19 à journaliste interroge joe biden
écouter est libre maintenant l'appeler à
démissionner étant donné que les
enquêteurs
le témoignage des 11 femmes étaient
crédibles je m'en tiens à cette
déclaration la police vous maintenant à
démissionner oui être mis en examen est
démis de ses fonctions prenons une chose
à la fois je pense qu'il devrait
démissionner je compte que le parlement
de l'état puisse décider de le
poursuivre mais je ne le sait pas avec
certitude
je n'ai pas pris connaissance de toutes
les données voilà donc l'étau qui se
resserre autour d' andrew comeau une
position qui devient de plus en plus
difficilement tenable pour lui surtout
que d'anciennes déclarations
ressurgissent de sa part notamment un
ancien tweet daté de 2013 où il a appelé
à la tolérance zéro pour toute personne
coupable d'harcèlement sexuel alors pour
le moment andrew comeau n'a toujours pas
démissionné mais la pression est très
forte d'ailleurs il ya une procédure de
destitution qui a été lancée dans l'état
de new york notamment sous l'impulsion
des démocrates
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
merci pour toutes ces précisions est les
talibans revendiquent l'attentât suicide
d'hier à kaboul la pression sur les
grandes villes s'accentue les insurgés
fort de plusieurs victoires continuent
leur avancée et s'approche
dangereusement des centres urbains est
les civils par milliers fuient les
combats et les précisions et d'hélène
masculine dieu est grand
mort aux talibans des habitants défilent
dans les rues de kaboul en soutien aux
forces afghanes
à deux heures d'intervalle deux fortes
explosions ont secoué la capitale avec
pour cible principale le domicile du
ministre afghan de la défense
ce soir des terroristes ont mené une
attaque suicide contre ma maison grâce à
dieu
cet incident n'a pas fait de dégâts
contre moi ou contre les membres de ma
famille mais malheureusement certains de
mes gardes ont été blessés
je veux assurer le peuple que ce genre
d'incident ne diminuera en rien ma
détermination à vous défendre vous et la
mère patrie la zone a finalement été
sécurisés dans la soirée cette attaque
au coeur de la capitale a été fermement
condamnées par les etats-unis
en quoi vous croyez nous condamnons sans
équivoque le bombardement et nous
continuons de soutenir nos partenaires
afghans
nous nous joignons à l'appel des
talibans et de toutes les parties à
mettre immédiatement fin à la violence a
accepté un cessez le feu permanent et
globale et à s'engager pleinement dans
des négociations de paix pour mettre fin
aux souffrances du peuple afghan
ces percées talibane dans les villes se
multiplient dans le pays
trois capitales provinciales sont
actuellement prises d'assaut par les
insurgés à lashkar gah ville de deux
cent mille habitants
des affrontements ont fait près de 40
morts en une journée
l'armée afghane appelle les habitants à
évacuer
à l'heure où tout le pays semble un peu
plus s'enliser dans la guerre civile
le président afghan ashraf ghani a
imputé ce lundi la détérioration de la
situation sécuritaire au retrait
précipité des troupes américaines et de
l'otan
désormais achevée à plus de 95% et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir
suivi jour retrouve à 21h rester avec
nous sur les français tout à l'heure
[Musique]
encore